smp leader in blackfoot thank you mr
speaker can i thank the prime minister
for advance copy of the statement and
welcome him back from his travels around
africa and europe and it's perhaps worth
reiterating mr speaker that all of us in
his house reiterate our support for
president vladimir for ukraine and their
struggle against the war criminal putin
mr speaker the scale and the depth of
the challenge facing our global
community is self-evident war in europe
the return of sorting inflation rising
interest rates and a cost of living
crisis that is punishing people in the
pocket we're not just faced with one
crisis this is an accumulation of crisis
that needs deserves and demands a
collective response
we know that at moments like this
solutions can only come from a
coordinated effort
previous efforts during the 2007
financial crisis and the coordination
dude included demonstrate just that
right across the world
and none of us should be in any doubt
the crisis we are now in is as very
bitter severe and steep and deep as
anything that we faced in the time of
the financial crisis but mr speaker so
far
and i regret to say this that the
collective effort that sense of urgency
has been badly lacking particularly from
organizations like the g7 the response
has been far too slow and far too small
prime minister
it is obvious that the g7 outcomes are
nowhere near enough
to combat the cost of living crisis that
we now face
so when can the public expect some
leadership and some action when will we
see a coherent coordinated and credible
plan to increase energy supply cap
prices and drive investment to the
global economy before recession becomes
inevitable
or is the plan really to delay until the
winter when things will only get worse
leadership now in responding to supply
shocks
will allow us to fight inflation or a
failure to take appropriate action
exposes all of us to longer lasting
inflationary risks
on ukraine can the prime minister
perhaps go a little bit further and give
us a
an outlook as to what we will do to make
sure that we can get grain out of
ukrainian reports
400 million people worldwide rely on
ukrainian food supplies this is now not
just about stopping war it's about
stopping famine too and finally i'm sure
the prime minister will agree that of
all these global efforts will only begin
and will only work if there is trust
between global leaders can the prime
minister therefore explain that in this
moment of many crisis how exactly
breaking international law and
threatening to start a trade war with
our neighbors
helps anyone
mister
yeah well thank you mr speaker actually
i think that uh he should look more
carefully at what the uh the g7 uh
produced in terms of the uh the plan to
cap prices for uh for oil and gas and
particularly to try to stop putin
profiteering as he currently is from his
uh from his illegal war there is a plan
it's not i won't pretend it's going to
be easy uh but we're doing as much as uh
as we can and we're certainly uh taking
a lot of other action for instance to
help countries around the world with
access to to fertilizer that they need
and he's right to raise the issue mr
speaker of the 25 million tons of of
grain currently uh held hostage in uh in
odessa uh there is a plan to get that
out it's it's not easy but well if you
look at the numbers we are gradually
getting more grain out of uh those
ukrainian silos uh back into uh europe
back into to africa and we will continue
uh to do that as for his final point mr
speaker uh about the uk and uh a
so-called breach of international i
really repeat what i i said to the right
on gentleman uh opposite uh what the
what the countries around the world see
is the uk offering consistent uh
consistent leadership uh in the matter
of standing up uh for the rule of law
and standing up against putin's
aggression and that is i promise you
that is what has been raised with me in
the last 10 days